chameleons tongues are fast and long  extending twice their body length in a  fraction of a second to find out just  how fast researchers used high speed  cameras to film different species of  chameleons as they targeted a suspended  cricket they found that smaller species  had faster stalks the one centimeter  long are spinosus can catapult its  tongue towards prey in over 2,500 metres  per second faster than any reptile bird  or mammal this incredible acceleration  is powered by 14 kilowatts per kilogram  of muscle the highest muscle power  output of any terrestrial vertebrate  smaller chameleons need to eat more food  each day to survive and so have  proportionally larger tongues for their  body size this allows them to propel  their tongues at accelerations of up to  264 G too fast for even the nimblest  cricket to outrun